[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO CARPO: Thank
you all for coming.
Thank you for the invitation.
Thank you for organizing this.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Thank you in advance
for your patience--
going to be very boring.
I am very jet lagged.
I may fall asleep while I speak.
If that happens, just
bring me a cup of coffee.
You, in compensation,
in the audience,
you may fall asleep anytime.
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess I have to tell you
something on new direction
in computer-aided design--
how advanced computation,
electronic computation,
has changed--
is changing architectural
design or architecture
in general, which is the
subject of my last book, which
is on some chairs.
Now, I understand
that most of you
are not architectural students,
nor architects, nor designers.
That's right?
Who is an architect here?
Raise your hand.
Well, you're a minority.
[LAUGHTER] What
are you doing here?
So that's good.
So I will just make a short,
more general introduction
to bring in my topic.
What do-- let me bring in my
pictures, which are somewhere.
Oh, yes.
I see it.
It's there.
What do architects do?
That's a very general query.
You know since
you're an architect.
Ask any architect.
They will tell you we build.
We do buildings, big buildings,
well, when we manage--
when we are successful.
Most of the time, we do not
manage, but that's the idea.
We make buildings.
Well, that's the idea, but it
is not actually, literally,
technically right, because
we, architects-- we
do not lay bricks.
We do not cut stone.
We do not carve wood.
We do not pour concrete.
We do not dig foundations.
We do not any of these
technical, physical, material
stuff.
Yes, we build buildings,
but we build buildings
by making drawings of buildings.
We make drawings, not buildings.
We make drawings,
clean drawings.
We give them to the builders,
and the builders, they,
will make the
buildings we design.
We do not make.
The designers do not build,
and the builders, they
are not allowed to design
or to change our design.
The kind of drawings
we give to the builders
are called blueprints, because
once upon a time, they were
blue, and they were printed.
Now they're no longer blue,
and they're no longer printed.
But we still call
them blueprints.
And it is thanks to blueprints,
to these kind of drawings,
that our profession
is not a craft.
It's a liberal art, an
intellectual activity.
We do not climb on scaffoldings.
We do not toil in the
snow, or in the rain,
or in the heat of summer.
We work in clean offices with
heating, ventilation, and air
conditioning.
And we are, most of the
time, even better paid
than the actual workers who make
the actual buildings happen.
That's the advantage of
being a notational art.
We build by notations-- by
making drawings, drawings which
eventually become buildings,
but we do not actually
make the buildings.
This is the advantage.
A disadvantage is
that, if you think
of a way a building
happens, we can only
build that of which
we can make a drawing.
If we cannot draw it, they,
the builders, cannot build it.
We are at the mercy of
the notational tools
we have at our disposal
to notate a building.
If we cannot draw it,
they cannot build it.
Now some geometrical shapes--
come on-- like this one
are very easy to notate.
That's a shoe box.
You make-- eight points
is enough to notate it--
or three points
and three vectors.
That's a really very easy
drawing to make, so that way,
notation is easy.
But think if what you
want to build that potato.
Now, since I was cooking last
night, I can actually show you.
Oops.
This is what I have in mind,
this awesome British potato.
If you want to build that
potato by notations--
plans, elevations,
and sections--
think of how many
drawings you have to make.
Each one of these points--
not one of these
points is aligned.
So you have to make a huge
number of sections in plans,
elevation, et cetera, et
cetera, because each point has
to be notated individually
and separately-- millions
and millions of point,
which will take millions
and millions of
drawings, which will take
a huge amount of time,
which is possible,
but it's not very practical,
because it takes too long.
So to build the shoe box,
it only takes eight points.
To build the potato, you must
make thousands and thousands
of drawings, each
slice, each section,
being different with different
points notated and measured in,
XYZ, in three dimensions, which
takes a heck of a lot of time--
which is one of the reasons why
potatoes were very seldom built
in the history of architecture
until computers came.
Because this kind of repetitive
boring operations, notating
each point-- xyz, three
measurements-- if you
have to notate 4 million points,
for us, it takes a lot of time.
A computer does it in
the blink of an eye.
So as of the early '90s,
when computer-aided design
became to be
affordable, you would
expect that architects start
building potatoes like crazy,
because there have been for
centuries, a pent up demand
for potatoes which
was never fulfilled,
because potatoes were
impossible to grow and build.
They are easy to make.
I could make this potato
in clay with my own hands.
That's easy.
But if I want to make
plans, elevation,
and section to scale--
to give a blueprint to the
builders to build the potato,
that takes a long time.
That was impossible
until 20 years ago--
not impossible, but impractical.
But now it's possible,
so you would expect
but as of the early '90s
or mid-'90s to see potatoes
everywhere.
And if you google--
you know what it means, right--
digital architecture, or
computational architectural,
or parametric
architecture, you will find
a mosaic of this kind of stuff.
And they are potato-esque, but
they are not real potatoes.
Because they are
around and smooth,
but they are streamlined,
and technological, and clean,
and almost mathematical.
A potato is rough
and disorderly.
These are not potatoes.
They are something else.
And as of the early '90s--
well, this is closer to
a potato but still not--
don't ask me which
kind of a building
this is, because it ain't one.
But it's still not
a potato, because it
is too smooth and too precise.
You can understand that
there is mathematics
in that, which isn't in this.
In the mid-'90s a colleague of
mine came out with a suitable
catchy term.
They decided to call these
new kind of digital shapes,
blobs, taking inspiration from
this science fiction movie
from the '50s.
And so, for a while, these
potato-esque digital stuff
were called blobs.
Today, they are called--
oops-- parametric or
parametric design.
But in truth--
and that's the way
I often tell the
story to my students.
If we look at the
actual timeline
of how these things came to
happen, these are not potatoes.
These are not blobs.
These are fish.
Because it all started
with this big fish,
which you may have seen if you
go to Barcelona on the beach.
Above the beach,
not in the water--
over the beach, there
is this huge metal fish
floating in mid air.
This was built by Western
architect Frank Gehry,
and this was the first time
Frank Gehry used software
for computer-aided design
for which, eventually,
it became famous--
a star architect which he is
now, but which he wasn't then.
And how is it that to build a
fish, Frank Gehry, at that time
already a well-known architect,
decided that he should
use computer-aided design?
And which kind of software
did he think he would need?
Well, think of it.
His problem was to model the
streamlined curve of the shape
of a skin of a fish.
And his argument was why is the
fish so streamlined and smooth?
Because it moves in water the
way a boat moves in water,
and the boat, the
hull of a boat,
has the same streamlined lines.
For a long time-- this is
a 17th century drawing--
shipbuilders have
had the technique
to make these curvy
pieces of wood
at the point of contact
between the hull
of the boat and the water.
Imagine the frame of a boat in
timber is given its structure.
And then you have to
nail this slat of timber
to the frame of the boat.
And they have to be
smooth, because that's
the point of contact
of the water.
With a boat, when the
boat moves in water,
there is friction, or drag.
And if the slat of
timber isn't smooth,
the boat will start to
rock, and it will slow down.
And this timber curvy
slats of the hull,
they have a name in English.
Since the 17th century, they
are called splines like a line
but sp before sp, splines.
In the dictionary,
you find this word
in use as of the 17th century--
technical term used
by craftsmen who
were building the hull
of boats by curving
with artisanal skills--
and each one, they did
in a different way--
these slats of
timbers, so that they
would connect a given number of
fixed points in the smoothest
continuous way.
Now the line of the stream--
the line where the
hull of the boat
touches the stream of
the incoming water--
the line of the stream
is called the streamline,
so this is the principle
of streamlining.
That's where it comes from.
The line of the stream,
that's the streamline, which
has to be smooth to
avoid friction, or drag.
And boats were built
this way for a long time,
and airplanes are
built this way too.
Because aerodynamic
and hydrodynamic
have the same principles.
This picture was made in
the mechanical engineering
department of Cornell
University doing World War II.
This is a team of engineers
designing the curve
of the wing of a fighter plane.
And we were still using the
same artisanal technique.
They are obtaining the line
of this curve by craft.
It all depends on the elasticity
of the material you're using,
so the kind of
timber you are using.
If you choose, I don't
know, pitch pine,
you get a certain curve.
If you use fir tree or
oak, a different one--
if you use as a same
material and you bent rubber,
you get a different color.
If you use melted
mozzarella cheese,
it would be a
different curve still.
That's the way it was then
even during World War II when
airplanes and wings of
airplanes were mass produced,
but they still did it
in this artisanal way.
And so, in the '50s and
'60s, the automobile industry
kept doing it by hand.
Oops.
This is probably the most
famously streamlined automobile
of all times.
Who knows the name of this car,
just for my personal curiosity?
Perhaps your
grandfather owned one.
Who knows it?
AUDIENCE: A DS?
MARIO CARPO: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: Is that the DS?
MARIO CARPO: It's the DS,
DS, which in French means
the divinity [INAUDIBLE] S--
designed in the early '50s.
By the way, this
masterpiece of French design
was entirely designed
by an Italian engineer,
and it came into
service in '56 or '57.
That was the car of General de
Gaulle, et cetera, et cetera.
But all this was made by hand.
And the way design was made,
when this car was produced,
was entirely artisanal.
The curves, the folding
curves, of the body of the car
were made first
in clay, and then
when the final design
of the car was ready,
it was made in hard wood.
There was no
blueprint of this car,
because nobody could have
made all the drawings
necessary to make all these
curves-- in plans, elevation,
and section was too complicated.
And so, the actual
design of the camera
was a model of a car in timber
kept in an atomic shelter
somewhere in central Paris.
So, you know, it was the Cold
War, so if something happened,
the design would stay there.
And when engineers needed
to drive blueprints
for any practical reason,
they went to the basement
into the atomic shelter, and
they measured the wooden model
in scale one to one.
They took the measurements out,
and they derived blueprints
as needed when needed.
It was laborious.
It was entirely artisanal,
which is why in the late '50s,
simultaneously at Citroen
and at Renault also in Paris,
the engineers,
designers, and the CEO
of two companies called their
top engineers and said, listen,
guys.
We know how you do it, by hand.
This has been done
that way for centuries.
Now you-- them speaking
to their engineers.
You are the best
engineers in the world.
The French always
think they are.
Now shouldn't there
be a way to notate
these curves using calculus,
x and y, a function-- the way
we learned it at school.
We can notate parabolas,
hyperboles, ellipsis, circles,
you name it.
Why should we not be able to
notate any curve whatsoever
in 3D just using three
letters and a little bit
of coefficients and
parameters-- mathematics.
Could you not do
it mathematically,
so it is more precise?
And one day-- one
day, who knows?
We may even use
computers to do that.
We don't have them now,
but one day we may.
And so, two teams started to
work in complete secrecy--
one at Citroen, one at Renault--
with the same
assignment, find a way
to notate this
using mathematics.
We now know the name of the
team leader at Renault--
and the name of the
team leader at Citroen
remained unknown
for a long time.
It's a fascinating chapter
in technological history.
These people evidently
knew each other.
They had studied in
the same schools.
They probably did the military
service in Nigeria together.
And their wives were probably a
member of the same rotary club
in central Paris.
But they had to work in
secret and in competition.
And we know that the Renault
team came up with some results
sooner.
It was the early '60s, when
they made a famous demonstration
in front of the CEO of
Renault. They took a signature
on a banknote--
where it is, you know, the
signature of the head cashier
of the Banque de France,
a doodle full of circles.
And they showed that
we have translated
that random curvy
doodle into formulas,
and they fed these
formulas into a plotter.
The plotter made the
drawing of the signatures
at the different scale,
and then at another scale,
and then at another scale.
Because the point is a
mathematical notation
has no scale, so it was
the same at every scale.
And it was a fantastic and
persuading demonstration.
And the CEO of Renault,
as to Pierre Bezier,
that was the top
engineer at Renault--
said good, fantastic.
Great work.
How long did it take
your team to translate
that doodle into mathematics?
Two years.
And how long would
it take to notate
the whole body of a car
using the same mathematics?
22 years.
Well then, that's
not very practical.
But they said, no, it
isn't if you do it by hand,
but one day computers will come.
And then they will
do it very fast.
Do we have these computers?
No.
Will we have these computers?
Are we going to
buy any computer?
Has anyone have any
computer in France?
No.
Perhaps the Americans
do, but we don't--
he says, well then,
shoot yourself.
That's what I presume
the CEO told to Bezier,
publish his pure mathematics,
no practical use--
publish it in some wacky
mathematical journals
and good luck, which they did.
They published it, 1966,
but only a few years later,
computers did come.
And so, these mathematics
was then open source,
as we would say.
It had been published--
scholarly journal.
Anyone could use
it, and everyone
started using it like crazy.
Renault, they built
their own software
for computer-aided
design called Uniserve.
In France, an aircraft
maker, Dassault,
developed its own
CATIA software.
In America, McDonnell Douglas,
General Motors, and Boeing
started to use it.
Boeing improved upon
it significantly.
They generalized the
mathematical notation
into something called
NURBS, Non-Uniform Rational
B-splines--
which in school of engineering
is an acronym meant to stand
for No One Understands
Really B-splines--
which means it's complicated.
The work at Citroen
was actually,
we now know,
mathematically better.
But the leader-- the
bosses at Citroen--
a private company.
Renault was state-owned--
decided that it
was an industrial secret.
They kept it in a
safe for 20 years,
so nobody could do
anything with it.
Pierre de [INAUDIBLE] is
the name of the other guy.
These kind of curves are
now called Bezier's curves,
from the name of Pierre
Bezier, or NURBS.
Fast forward to 1991 or '90
when the office of Frank Gehry
had that problem I told you.
They wanted to design
that fish, and they
knew or [INAUDIBLE] with
some reason that not really
shipbuilders but aircraft
makers would have
the technology they
needed, because they
knew part of the story.
And so, Frank Gehry
was in Los Angeles.
McDonnell Douglas
was-- and still
is not called McDonnell
Douglas-- south of Los Angeles,
so they made a phone call
which is not recorded.
But we can imagine
something like that.
Consider that in 1990-'91,
Frank Gehry was not yet a star
architect.
He was known among
the architects,
but people outside
the profession
didn't really know about him.
So imagine the call--
office of Frank Gehry to
the technological office
of McDonnell Douglas.
[INAUDIBLE] office
of architects.
We have to build a big fish.
Can you help?
Sorry, guys.
You have the wrong numbers.
We are not in the fish
building business.
We do birds, big
birds, airplanes.
And [INAUDIBLE] yes, but
the mathematics is the same.
And [INAUDIBLE] yes, sure.
My name is Napoleon.
Good luck.
But Frank Gehry didn't
take no for an answer.
He tried again--
called the MIT--
his friend, Bill Mitchell,
then head of architecture
at the MIT--
one of the founders of
computer-aided design.
He said, oh, don't
try with those.
You know whom you should
call-- these crazy guys
at Dassault in Paris.
They made these fantastic
fighter jet, the Mirage,
so expensive that no army
can buy it except the French.
And they have this
fantastic software
for designing splines,
which is called CATIA--
so complicated that no engineer
can use it except their own.
Call them, they
may have something.
And he did call them, and
they said, sure, sure.
A fish, seashells, the
snakes, elephant tusks,
all kinds of organic
cures, that's our business.
We would be happy to help.
A team of Dassault engineers
went to Los Angeles.
They worked together.
They simplified CATIA to make
it suitable to architectural
design, and they
produced something
which was used to make
the fish you have seen.
Frank Gehry liked
that stuff so much
that he kept using
CATIA and building fish.
He has been building
fish all over the world,
and he's now famous as the
most famous fish builder
in the history of architecture.
The original fish-- I know it
from, Frank Gehry, himself,
it was actually meant
to be a carp, which is--
I think it's OK,
considering my family name.
It doesn't look like a
carp, but then immediately
after he built, of course,
the Guggenheim Bilbao
using the same software,
CATIA, simplified
for architectural purposes.
And he went on building the same
kind of spliney fishy curves
all over the world.
This is the Guggenheim Bilbao
integrated in '96 or '97,
but this is the Philharmonic
in Los Angeles a bit later.
This is very recent.
It is in Paris.
And this is now Gehry's
signature style--
the style of a fish, because
of the spline modeling software
he's using.
Now he was so successful in
using this adaptation of CATIA
for architectural
purposes that he
copyrighted a simplified
version of CATIA for architects.
We call it Digital Projects.
He founded an
independent company
called Gehry
Technologies, providing
fish making to other companies,
who didn't have the expertise.
And he made so much money with
this company, which eventually,
he sold the company--
which is now an independently
owned company still called
Gehry Technologies-- but
owned by another company--
to do that.
Most normal offices of
architecture and students
in school cannot use CATIA.
It's too complicated
and too expensive.
They use cheaper, simpler,
crappier software,
who include some of the
same spline modeling tools
called Rhino, Maya, formZ.
You may have heard
some of these names.
They have all been developed
in the course of the '90s,
and they are now
universally used.
So all these, if
you look at them
after the story I told you, you
should not see them as blobs,
but you should see them as fish.
Look at this fish.
This is fish-- fish.
Some of them were never built.
Some of them were built.
This looked like a Photoshop,
but this is a real building.
This is a real building too.
This looks like a real
building, but it was never built
and never will be, et
cetera, et cetera--
fish, fish design.
Now the problem is if you go
to my school over there one
mile in that direction or to
a handful of other schools
which are from the avant
garde of design innovation,
and you look at what our
students or my colleagues
have been doing for the
last five or six years--
and this is a selection
of what they do--
they do not look
like fish at all.
The style is
completely different.
This is what I call, in my
book, the second digital style.
It's disjointed, disconnected,
broken, fragmentary.
Continuity has been
replaced by discreteness.
It is not smooth.
It is rough.
And I was trying to
explain to my students.
Well, this is what one of
my colleagues has done.
Since I tell the story
with metaphors or analogs--
the potato, the fish--
I was looking for another
animal to describe this.
And they thought it
would be a sheep.
The problem is with my accent--
and many of my
students also speak
English as a foreign
language-- if I say sheep,
no one will ever understand if
I mean the boat or the animal.
So I had to find
something easier,
so I decided to call it a dog.
It looks like a
dog a little bit,
but I was teaching American
during the foreign.
American students are demanding
more than our British students,
and so when one of the students
came to me after class--
professor, which kind of
dog do you have in mind?
And the students
produced this vignette
showing that not all dogs
look like that [INAUDIBLE]..
See, this is a modernist
dog, which is streamlined
as if it were a fish.
You know, everything in
this picture is streamlined.
It's a model in this picture.
And you will see
the fish itself.
So now the dog
looks like a fish,
and the fish looks like
a ballistic missile.
And because the modernism
was all about streamlining.
Everything is
streamlined, even the dog.
The fish is normal.
It's streamlined by nature.
The dog shouldn't
be, but it was made.
Now this is the
dog I have in mind.
This is a postmodern dog, which
gives an idea of complexity,
and, you know,
discreteness, and messiness.
This is clean, but I would
imagine that in normal life,
this dog is actually
quite dirty.
So this is what is going on.
So the question is since
evidently computer-aided design
is driven by the tools-- the
technical tools we are using
and then by the
performance of the machines
we are using, why is it that the
style of computer-aided design
has shifted from fish
making to dog making?
Was the software of
the '90s more fishy,
or is the software today
more inclined to being dog?
As you probably
know, computers still
do today what they did 20 years
ago, or even 30 years ago,
or 20 years ago.
But we are much faster, and
more powerful, and cheaper.
For the last 5 or 10
years, we got so used
to this wealth of
data that we even
invented a new
definition to define
this new data rich environment.
We call it big data--
to define this notion
that, for a long time,
data was supposed to
be rare and expensive.
Now it's ubiquitous and cheap.
It's a big, you
know, upheaval of
the anthropological
condition of humankind
from the beginning of time,
still 10 years ago, we always
needed more data than we had.
For the last few years,
it is, as we always had,
more data than we need.
So we call this big data, or
we have a number of other terms
to define the same machine
learning, deep learning,
artificial neuro--
which I don't know what
it is-- blah, blah, blah.
Or you can read all this.
And there is a notion
that some of these
may somehow be already
related to an idea
of artificial
intelligence, which is odd
because, for people
my age, we used
to think that artificial
intelligence was something that
would come one
day in the future.
And now we are being
told we have already
been using it for the last five
years without even knowing,
which is odd.
And I don't know what
artificial intelligence is.
Perhaps you know.
You will tell me
after during coffee.
But I can tell you
what is starting
to happen in design
when we start
to use some of this big data,
or deep learning, or machine
learning, or even
artificial intelligence
tool in the ordinary
practice of our work trade.
And I will show you a couple of
examples to give you an idea.
Since we are talking
about curves,
which is why I gave you
this long introduction,
this is the normal
human mathematical way
to notate a curve.
We will studied it at school.
This is a parabola.
And the magic of calculus is
that with-- two letters x, y--
and three coefficients, or
parameters, numbers-- a, b,
and c--
we notate an infinite
number of points.
How many points
sit on this curve--
a huge number of them, an
infinite number of them.
But a simple line of
plain mathematical script
as long as this is enough
to notate all the points
we need that sit on that curve.
That's the way we do it.
That's a very
brilliant way to do it,
because it compresses
a huge amount of data
into a very short clean
and memorable notation--
so memorable that I
studied 100 years ago,
and I still remember it even
though I really never used it.
But this is the way we do
it, and this is increasingly
the way a machine, or artificial
intelligence, would do it--
not by using the function
but by making a long list--
a long list of points.
For each x, there is a y,
which is located on that curve.
And you make that list.
And I remember making this
list, when I was a high school
student, to check that the point
really sat on the parabola--
that you cannot notate
every point that way.
The purpose of
scripting the function
is precisely that you do not
need to indicate each point
one by one, because the
script indicates them
all in a single line.
But for a computer, from a
computer's point of view,
making a list of 1,000
points, or 1 million points,
or 1 billion points
is not a big deal.
It is for us, because we
cannot work with that list.
But a computer can manipulate
a list of 1 billion points
in the blink of an
eye, which is indeed
what is already starting to
happen in architectural design.
Because if you look at
this, a famous fish,
built recently by Zaha Hadid--
well, when she was still alive--
one of her last buildings
before she died
tragically two years ago.
It's huge.
It's the biggest fish
ever built, I think.
You can see it from the
moon with the naked eye.
It's enormous.
But the mathematical
script is more--
just two lines or three lines
of script or perhaps a bit more,
but it is mathematics.
You can recognize that
it is mathematical
because this curve,
this streamlined curve,
looks familiar.
This is something that
we recognize something--
ours, because we know the
mathematics underpinning it.
It has been around
for quite a long time.
Calculus was invented at
the end of the 17th century.
Bezier's mathematics
between 1958 and 1964,
you don't need computers
to use that mathematics,
but with computers,
it's ran faster--
because more affordable.
That's, you know-- they weren't
as we knew it even though it
is a bit bigger
than what we used
to do using that kind of tools.
If you look at this--
built recently by
Michael Hansmeyer--
a 3D-printed grotto using the
biggest to-date commercial 3D
printer.
You can 3D print a single
block in the size of a room.
And each part of these
3D-printed structure
is printed as a voxel.
A voxel is a little
unit of matter,
which is calculated
individually and separate.
It's like an atom in
three dimensions, xyz--
the smallest unit of this
volumetric composition.
And if you look at
it close up, that's
the belly of that grotto.
This grotto was made by 3D
printing 4 billion voxels,
one by one--
each one notated,
calculated, and fabricated.
For each voxel, there is a
notation and a calculation,
for billions of them.
We couldn't work that way,
because if we print out
that list, it would
start here and finish
in another continent.
But a computer can run that
list in the blink of an eye,
so this way of working,
which is absurd for us,
makes perfect sense
for a machine.
Because we can not work that
way, but the machine can.
And if this composition
looks a bit weird, and wacky,
and strange, there
is a reason for that.
It is already the expression
of an intelligence
which is not ours.
This is the outward
and visible sign
of an inward invisible logic
at play, a logic which is not
the natural logic of our mind.
It is the artificial
logic of a machine.
A machine can do that,
because the machine thinks
in a way which is different
from the way we think.
If we use a formula,
we don't do that.
If we use a list of
points, we could do that.
But how many points can
be manipulated by hand
or using a slide ruler?
Not many.
These are 4 billion
points, and it shows.
It is a complexity,
or richness, of data,
which the machine can
manage, but we can't.
This is the way
the machine thinks.
That's not the way we think.
Another example-- this
is not a Photoshop.
It was actually built
in Germany, Stuttgart,
by Achim Menges.
And it is a small pavilion.
It was built in a public space.
And this being Germany,
before you build it,
you need permission from the
local office for something,
which has to validate your
structural calculation to make
certain that this building would
withstand the wind of x knots
and will also withstand the
weight of certain [INAUDIBLE]
of snow--
something like that.
So you have to provide
structural calculation, which
have to be validated
by a public office,
to certify that the
building is safe--
structural calculation,
structural design.
How do you think this building,
which is made of filaments,
was calculated?
Using these
structural formulas--
these are the formulas
I studied at school--
to the limit-- with a lot
of effort of imagination,
we could use these mathematics
and this engineering
to calculate each filament
individually, but there, again,
probably 4 million
filaments in that shell.
So if you want to calculate
each filament individually,
in principle, it is possible.
In practice, it
would take six years.
So we would not really do it.
Yet the structure
was calculated,
but how did they do it?
Not using traditional structural
formulas-- using something
called finite element analysis,
the computational version.
I shall not go into
details which, by the way,
I don't know very well myself.
But the way it works is
that you see on the screen
a simulation of a
structure, and you
simulate in the simulation
a certain load--
wind, or snow, or whatever.
What you see on the screen
is that part of the structure
starts to blink red--
what time is it?
At what time did I-- yes.
Well, we are on time.
It started blinking red, on the
screen, the part that we break.
So what you do?
You tweak it.
And you change it, and you
try again another load--
and if you blink
red, somewhere else--
and again and again.
And you try and you keep
trying until you see something
on the screen that
doesn't blink red.
Everything is green.
That means it will not collapse,
so that's the good one--
the one you will build.
The problem is you have to keep
trying, and trying, and trying.
And you have no clue as to
which trial will give the best
result. The trials are fast,
because they are in simulation,
which is why, to make
the progress even faster,
we ask the machine to
keep trying automatically.
And we can call
that optimization.
Machine keeps trying,
and trying, and trying.
And the machine does, say, 1
million trials in one hour,
and chances are that some
of these will be good.
And the one which the machine
finds will be among the best.
One of them will be
built, but nobody
knows which changes will
give the best results.
How do you think this was
calculated before it was built?
It was calculated,
but it was calculated
the way I told you-- by
simulation and trial and error
on the screen.
Why does this one structure
stand up and the 9,999 just
tried in computational
simulation didn't?
Nobody knows it, least
of all is designers.
And yet we know--
and yet we know that
it will stand up,
which is why we can build it.
Because in simulation,
we know it did withstand.
So what we call simulation
and optimisation is
massive computational
trial and error--
try, and try, and try,
and try, and keep trying.
Or in another way is
the art and science
of finding good solutions
without knowing why they work.
So in a nutshell, it is
already evident that artificial
intelligence-- and this is
artificial intelligence,
which to some extent it is--
it works.
We can already use it to
solve problems we couldn't
solve in any other way.
But it works in a way which
is different from the way we
would work.
It already shows
a logic at play,
which is different from the
logic of our mind, which
is probably a good reason
to call it artificial.
Because our organic intelligence
would not solve problems
that way.
The artificial intelligence
of a machine cam
already solve problems
in a different way, which
in many cases is the
only way to solve
problems of a given complexity.
So yes, it works, but it works
in a way which we may find--
well, which is different
from the way we think,
which is probably one
reason why we should call
this intelligence, artificial--
because the organic logic of
our mind doesn't work that way.
Think of what we did not do.
In the case of a function,
we cannot calculate 4 million
points one by one.
The machine does, and
the machine does it.
In the case of
structural design,
we cannot run 4 million
trials in a sequence,
because it would take forever.
But the machine does
it in 20 minutes.
So trial and error, which
is a very stupid strategy
for humans, is a very good
strategy for the machine.
If I look for a formula to
put all these into tag line,
I don't have to look very far,
because you people have already
found it 14 years ago
when you launched Gmail
with this type of
search, don't sort.
Because if you think of what
I just told you, what we do--
we humans-- we sort.
We take data, and
we organize them
and structure them to make them
smaller, and more functional,
and more understandable.
That's the way our mind,
and traditional science,
and mathematics always worked.
A computer can search so
fast, but this sorting
is often unnecessary.
Because by the speed
of the processing
of the simple sorting process,
sequential, a computer
can find the best solution,
but we with our slow searching
would.
Think of names in
a telephone book
or in a telephone directory.
1 million names, we have to
sort them alphabetically,
so we know where our name
is when you look for it,
and we don't have to read
all the names to find
the name we're looking for.
But a computer can do just that.
The computer can read 1
million names in two seconds.
So our sorting, which
is indispensable for us,
is unnecessary for the
machine, because the machine
can search so fast that the
preliminary sorting, which
we need, is not
necessary for them.
Think of books in a library.
We put books on a
shelf for following
a system of logic
of classification,
so we know where certain
subject is when we look for it.
We put things in
certain places, so we
know where things are
when we look for them.
So the shelf mark
or the code number--
if you're looking for a book
on architecture, Renaissance,
the 16th century
Florence churches--
it's a formula, a shelf mark.
And with that number,
you go to that shelf,
and you find the
book you're looking
for without having to
read the titles of all
the books in the library--
which would take forever.
A computer can do it.
And with virtual reality,
we can do that as well.
Think of-- instead of
using a librarian--
when all the books come in, you
tag them with radio frequency
identification-- a little chip--
then you put them in a
huge mountain, no sorting
whatsoever.
Then you fire all
your librarians,
and you buy a pair of
virtual reality glasses.
And when you're looking for
that book in that mountain
and saying, where is that book?
And you would see blinking
red in your field of vision,
so you don't need
librarians to sort,
because the machine can search.
Search or sort?
We sort-- human intelligence.
Computers search--
artificial intelligence.
But that's not my cup of tea.
To go back to my
cup of tea, which
is potatoes, and
fish, et cetera,
it is evident that our
computational design,
it's a fascinating
testing ground already
for artificial intelligence,
because the stuff we do
is so simple and so cheap.
And the software we use is
so, you know, elementary.
And we do physical stuff--
the feedback loop, you know, the
verification is also immediate.
Start in the morning,
and by the evening
we know if it will stand up,
or if it will break down.
And we know what we
would look like--
verification is faster probably
than in many other trades
and professions, which
is why we can probably
redesign as some architects.
We can probably intuit
the spirit of this game
sooner and faster than
many other professions do,
because we have an
immediate physical feedback.
If it falls down,
it doesn't work,
so we have to try another.
So if we are lucky, we can hope
to glean the spirit of the game
sooner and perhaps better than
some other professions do,
but the problem is
this is not our game.
This was never our game.
It was never meant
to be our game,
because this is your game.
You came up with it.
We didn't.
So this is where I should stop
speaking and start listening.
I think we have still
a few minutes for that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOST: So we have 10
minutes for questions.
Yeah, right here.
AUDIENCE: You had
so many choices.
Hi.
You said you actually
were an expert
in classical architecture.
How do you see this as an
evolution of what the Greeks
and Romans were trying to do?
Because there's are quite
mathematical as well,
their architecture.
Do you think this is just
the evolution of that,
or is this something
totally different?
MARIO CARPO: Well,
architecture is always
at the mercy of the tools
we use to make it happen.
That's inevitable.
To some extent,
every expression is
at the mercy of the tool
we use to manifest it.
You can think that
language is natural,
but in fact, when your ideas are
manifested through the alphabet
or through syntax,
the tools that you
use to communicate feedback
on the kind of message
you can, you know, transmit.
This feedback loop is inevitable
in every human expression.
In the case of architecture, if
you compare it with painting,
the technical bottleneck
is more determinant.
Of course, a painter
is at the mercy
of the kind of canvas he's
using and the technology
of the colors he's
putting on the canvas,
but you can think that
that technological--
the limitation, it's not
much if you compare it
with the technical implication
of building a big building.
And we are particularly
at the mercy
of tools of
quantification, because we
have to measure a building
before it is built,
and that was always
the case in Greek,
and Roman, and
classical architecture--
not so much for
costing or estimate,
which is important today,
but for proportions,
which, for them, was a
matter of vital importance.
And evidently, if you look at
Roman or Greek architecture,
you can glean, from the way
the buildings are built,
the kind of tools
of quantification
they used to make it happen,
which was not number based,
because the Greek and Roman
didn't have good numbers,
and they didn't trust numbers.
It was all based on geometry.
What we would solve
by using, you know,
Hindu-Arabic numbers--
which evidently we didn't have--
the numbers they had were crap,
and so they couldn't use
them to calculate anything.
But their geometry
was first class.
We still use it.
So all that quantification
was achieved through Euclidean
geometry tools, whereas the
arithmetic number-based tools
we use today didn't yet exist.
You know, the Greeks
always mistrusted numbers.
They preferred geometry
were all in the compass,
the typical tool of the masons.
The quantification of
the proportional harmony
of those buildings derived from
that use of geometry, which
is why neoclassical architecture
as of a 17th century
or 18th century-- which
is number-based and not
geometrical determined-- from
a distance, it looks the same.
But if you look at it
with the eye of an expert,
you can tell that
it's no longer Euclid.
It is numbers.
Those numbers were
pure arithmetics.
The story I've told you
is how quantification
shifted from
algebra to calculus,
because this is what Bezier
and the French teams did.
In a sense, that
was the culmination
of the dreams of
Western mathematics,
because with Descartes,
Leibniz, and Newton,
we could not eat conics--
you know, parabolas, hyperboles,
et cetera, et cetera.
With Bezier, it was, in
a sense, the culmination
of the dream of
mathematicians of all time.
You can notate, using
a mathematical script,
everything.
A cloud in the sky, a
flower in the field,
any shape and form in
nature can be scripted
as a mathematical notation.
Of course, we didn't need to
notate the cloud or a flower.
We need to notate
the body of a car.
And it was complicated, but
with computers, it became easy.
Which is why when
computers became available,
first thing we did-- we didn't
use them to make potatoes.
We used them to make fish,
because that's mathematics,
and there is no
mathematics in a potato.
We call this freeform,
because there is
no mathematics embedded in it.
And in a sense, that dog,
the last part of my story,
is closer to the
potato than the fish.
So in a sense, we are
getting back to a potato,
but with a delay of 24 years.
But the feedback loop
back to your question--
at every point in time, the
kind of architectural shapes
and form you see--
if you look at it as an
historian of science,
you can read in
the physical shape,
the tools of
quantification which were
essential to make it happen.
That doesn't mean that I can
do that for every period.
I can only do it for some
little passages in it,
but that's the game.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
an interesting historical
introduction.
I have a followup question
to the previous one.
Could you please feed
the work of Gaudi
to these fishes, dogs, and
the straight lines story?
MARIO CARPO: Could you do what?
AUDIENCE: Could you please put
the work of Gaudi into this?
MARIO CARPO: The work
of Gaudi, Antoni Gaudi?
AUDIENCE: Yes, yes-- into
this this scheme of fishes,
and the dogs, et cetera?
MARIO CARPO: Well, Gaudi was
a very important reference
of the beginning
of a digital term
in the '90s, because Gaudi--
who is not a dog and not a fish.
It doesn't belong to any
historical parameters,
because it was a one off.
It was an isolated genius,
who due to a remarkable set
of circumstances was allowed
in Barcelona to make something
happen, which is a miracle--
which should in theory
never have existed.
He wanted to reenact the way
of building of medieval master
builders, so he was
building without notations.
In the Middle Ages,
architectural blueprints
did not exist.
Craftsmens, there
was no separation
between the designers
and the builders.
The master builders were
conceiving and making
at the same time
on site on the fly.
And in 1890 until 1910, Antoni
Gaudi in industrial Barcelona
wanted to revive due to
his ideology, to his faith,
to his inspiration--
wanted to revive
the medieval way of building.
He didn't want to
revive a style.
He wanted really to revive
a social organization
of a medieval
building site, so he
wanted to devise a
way of being where
there's no designer
separated from the builder.
The builder is a
master builder, who
decides every day what
is going to build.
In an industrial world,
you cannot build that way.
But in Barcelona,
at that time, he
found illuminated
sponsor, who decided
that he should build a
big cathedral that way--
to the superior glory
of god, which he did.
And the building
is still going on,
because a medieval
cathedral, since it
has no design has no
beginning and no end.
So long as there is someone
who is willing to build,
the building will keep growing.
And as of the mid-'90s,
someone I know, Mark Burry,
took on from where Gaudi stopped
using computer-aided design,
because he thought with some
reason that using CAD/CAM--
computer-aided design and
computer-aided fabrication--
it is easier to reenact the
medieval way of building.
Because if you work
with computers,
you can design and make
almost at the same time,
because you're using
the same machine.
The same tool that puts
a picture on the screen
can print it out,
so the separation
between designer and
maker is compressed
by the tool you're using.
So in a sense, this
use of a computer
is more medieval than modern,
which is why they are now--
they are now still building
the Sagrada Familia
using computers-- in a sense
continuing and interpreting
Gaudi's dream of
reviving the Middle Ages.
It's a fascinating story.
Thanks for bringing it up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
which technique Gaudi
used to some sketches.
I think that, even though
he built recently by himself
and leads the process, he had
some drawings of cathedral.
MARIO CARPO: He had
diagrams not blueprints,
because stereotomy, which is the
medieval technique for cutting
stone, you can not represent it.
But there are ways to teach
to the artisans how to do it.
And in the case of some
complicated curves,
he actually used
catenary models,
which we are still using,
to determine the shape
of some arches and their load.
And in that, he was
probably bringing
in a technology which the
medieval builders would not
have known.
So he was probably tweaking
his own rules a little bit.
But I don't think there
are drawings by Gaudi.
Diagrams, yes-- sketches made
after the building has been
built, yes-- but blueprint, no.
Because that is contrary.
It goes contrary to his spirit.
A blueprint is an
instruction, which
a thinker gives to a maker.
In the medieval
scheme of things,
that separation does not exist.
If you build, you
think and make.
As an artisan, you
don't have a blueprint.
You don't receive a
blueprint to execute.
You decide, every
day in the morning,
what you will do during the
day, because that's medieval.
The architectural profession,
which I described,
was invented in the
Renaissance when
the humanists, a bunch of snobs,
decided that designers should
make and that ideas should have
an intellectual value which
is superior to actual craft,
but that is a modern invention.
It was invented in the 15th
century with the Renaissance.
In the Middle Ages, the
separation did not exist.
This is what Gaudi had in mind--
to revive the Middle
Ages, because he did not
like modernity even though the
money used to build the Sagrada
Familia was being earned by the
modern industrial development
in Barcelona, but
that's the way it works.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks very much for the talk.
There was a sense that
maybe in the '80s and '90s,
maybe with CAD/CAM, other
technologies, or software,
that some things started
to look quite similar.
Like, cars started to
resemble each other.
Like, an Audi looked
like a BMW or whatever.
Do you think, with
AI machine learning,
that there will be
more of that, or it
will be that things become more
differentiated in their design?
MARIO CARPO: It is
true, particularly,
as you rightly point out,
in the case of car design.
These kind of curves, the
splines, the mathematics
was the same in the software
used by all car makers
at the time, the
software was not.
And each software
has its own tweaks.
So I'm not
particularly an expert,
but Greg Lynn, one of the--
whose work I have shown--
was very much interested
in car design.
He's a real expert
and connoisseur.
He tells-- I have no evidence
of that-- but by looking
at the body of a car, he can
tell which release of a given
software was used to make it,
and it is true to some extent.
There are tweaks of each
software which leave traces.
So sometimes you can tell
which release of Word
was used to compose a certain
text, because, you know,
cut and paste works in a
different way or something.
So insofar as that
was the early--
you can do that because
there were probably
25 kinds of software
being used in the '90s
by all automotive
industry in the world,
so if you are in that
field, you know them all.
Now we are probably
moving to an environment
where there is much more
and faster variations
than adaptations, so
my guess is that game
of recognizing the indexical
trace of the tools we're using
is not going to be
that easy anymore.
Because in the '90s,
there were probably
25 variations of a
certain software,
and now there are
probably 1,000.
And then, that game is--
so I think that
complexity, which
is coming through artificial
intelligence tools,
will make this kind of
thing lexical transference
of the tool into the traces
of it's use less conspicuous.
HOST: All right then--
MARIO CARPO: That's it.
HOST: --that's all we
have time for, yeah.
MARIO CARPO: Good
HOST: Thank you very
much for coming.
MARIO CARPO: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]